walk downtown in seattle and you're
likely to come across this
oh sorry i mean this
it's technically an amazon office
but really it's a gaudy showpiece
look at us we're amazon we built a
rainforest smack dab in the middle of
seattle and encased it in silver balls
because we can
it's the kind of thing that seems like a
good idea right after you've drained
your blood boy
but that you later regret
next thing you know you have to build a
stand right by your giant balls and give
away free fruit all day as an apology
we're sorry for what we've done have as
many bananas as you'd like
[Music]
[Music]
seattle's obscene wealth has turned the
real estate market here into a brutal
free-for-all
just ask these people
the like sprint to find permanent
housing here whether you're buying or
renting is
insane and to actually buy a place is
feels out of the realm of possibility
unless you're a millionaire it just
seems like it keeps getting worse and
worse the inventory is pretty tight i
didn't it's hard to find really good
stuff i think renting was easier i was
kind of shocked at how expensive
everything is and how competitive the
market is the seattle housing scene in
one word um
crazy
i'd say it's a gauntlet cutthroat
trouble
[Music]
to learn about the latest in seattle
real estate and the art of selling a
home here i went straight to the top
let's roll
i paid a visit to my old friend glenn
kellman the ceo of redfin i should warn
you
that
almost no one is willing to get in the
car with me while i'm driving
and if at any point you need to grab the
wheel to save us from death i won't feel
about the the yellow terrible yeah it's
elon musk
just being opinionated to be opinionated
without actually being better i have
this theory by the way
i think about
when people can stand up to ceos all the
time because i worry that people can't
stand up to me
and for me the
signal version of that is jar jar binks
where clearly
no one could tell george lucas what a
racist disaster jar jar was
because he was surrounded by 100 like 18
layers
of psycho fence
i think no one could tell elon
this is an accident waiting to happen
this steering wheel
and i can't figure out
what mistakes redfin is making that no
one has the courage to tell me about
i used redfin back in uh yeah i didn't
know that yeah yeah i told you you
didn't know no
i store that [ __ ] i should have said the
s word but no you can't the uh no you
did because i had gotten to know you and
i was like oh fine i'll give this red
fin thing a try then i feel like you
dated me when i was a teenager
it's so much better now
so technology is supposed to make
industries more efficient with real
estate we just found the perfect foil
where you have an agent
who
isn't always acting in the customer's
best interest but also charging a high
price and so we thought
that by using technology we could make
the agent more efficient
we're on our way to see a home that
redfin bought refurbished and then sold
for a profit
buying and flipping homes like this is a
huge risk for the company
just ask zillow
if housing prices go down redfin might
get stuck with money losing inventory
glenn's belief is that redfin can use
its technology and experience to lower
the risks it analyzes thousands of data
points to monitor quick changing trends
in housing markets across the country a
mix of machine learning algorithms and
computer vision tell redfin where to buy
homes and what quick fixes will result
in the best returns
[Music]
first of all there's just
the fundamental problem of trying to
figure out what a home is worth
and
the reason that you need machine
learning algorithms rather than standard
computer science is because
a basement is very valuable in seattle
whereas a pool is valuable in atlanta
it is constantly reevaluating what
factors right matter
the most
and so
one of them is a pricing algorithm and
then another one
is about renovations and computer vision
and trying to assess the quality of the
property based on photos oh okay
the little house here used to look like
this
cozy but not exactly seattle's finest
unless you're in to smoke tinged
yellowing walls
redfin has revamped the place in the
hopes of kicking its price higher
and heather here is one of redfin's
chief revampers this isn't necessarily
someone's individual personality and you
know we're just trying to position the
house so people can see what the
potential is
she's promised me some top tips
[Music]
so we want to keep it kind of neutral
are there any other like just tiny
details that people wouldn't think of
like the kind of i think anything that
you touch right so like that's why we
want to put in new plumbing fixtures or
we want to make sure like there's new
knobs because i think that people that
makes it you know feel like it's a good
experience okay yeah now that makes
sense the simplest thing that has the
highest roi
is just
update the kitchen without replacing it
[Music]
paint is just transformative so
paint your whole house and keep it
neutral makes sense make sure your
flooring is consistent
this might seem like normal renovation
stuff but it's all pulled from redfin's
algorithms
we're doing 5000 sales a year and we're
capturing data about what works and
doesn't and the simplest lesson is to
not overdo it when we have lost our
shirt it's almost always doing too much
not too little how many times did you
screw it up before you guys you know is
this this is if we stop screwing it up
the promise of redfin has long centered
on lowering commission rates and trying
to modernize real estate in some of its
dubious practices
redfin however has faced recent
criticism and even been sued for
offering better services to affluent
customers
glenn says he takes these critiques to
heart and he promises that he's more
than some rich guy capitalizing off a
crazed real estate market
people pay 60 to 80 billion dollars in
real estate commissions and no one would
ever pay that if you actually had to dig
out your wallet and hand a real estate
agent thirty or forty thousand dollars
so
technology is supposed to make
industries more efficient the second
part of it is more about social justice
that still
lenders who decide that someone who is
latino or black is less likely to be
able to afford a home and even if they
got the same income
like why would your agents be less
inclined to do those sorts of things
than
others historically you can't control
any human being
um in every way but we can certainly say
that when you list a home you need to
make sure that everybody can see that
it's for sale instead of just posting it
on facebook
which has become especially popular in
silicon valley you give people fair
housing training so i'm not trying to
get on my high horse on this one
and say that we're the end all and be
all of fair housing but
the way that housing has been working
over the past 50 years can't be the way
it works over the next 50.
okay so you've been in seattle now for a
while i know you don't want to
bad-mouth the home team but you were i
love seattle but you felt like
vancouver's kind of where the action is
or
yeah well it's almost a tale of two
cities because
first of all vancouver just has
different zoning than seattle so when
you go there you'll see it sometimes
feels like hong kong
it's very dense and bustling and seattle
has begun to address that
um but for a long time what really
shaped the seattle skyline was
this rumor among developers that jeff
bezos
didn't like buildings
that were taller than 8 or 12 stories
the windows had to open
and it had to be tall enough or low
enough that you could take the stairs
and now the second part
is that canada is outranking the united
states as a destination for
international tech talent that you have
all these foreign students
who believe in the canadian dream
instead of the american dream and
i think it's really becoming this tech
center
some of it's urban planning and some of
its immigration policy yeah
but you're gonna you're hanging tight in
seattle when you actually think
about turning in your american passport
yeah and becoming canadian
and pumping your gas in leaders
it's still a step yeah
[Music]
no trip to seattle is really complete
without some time on the water
if you're lucky enough you can find a
nerdy sea captain who will take you out
with his crew
nathan here used to work with the other
nathan at intellectual ventures
then he started a company called kymeta
that made crazy antennas
and now he started another company named
rendered ai
it makes something called synthetic data
how are you making the first image of
this fake
x-rays literally you can build 3d models
you know in blender or other tools and
then simulate them using that this would
just be to make many many many x-ray
images that then get fed into a machine
learning system so see what it can you
bought you go through the airport right
yeah
they of course scan your baggage
um and that's going through an ai of
course you know how they train that ai
they literally have people pack bags and
pass them through that so they can be
like that's a knife
that's a banana
that is done by hand today okay
so as you can see that has some gaps
they just have people spending thousands
of hours passing
things through they do okay modern
machine learning ai needs to go through
a process called training where it's fed
tons of data in order to learn how to do
a task
redfin for example feeds its algorithms
data about real estate
but unlike redfin not every company has
tons of information at its disposal to
train its machine learning algorithms so
what rendered ai does is manufacture
data out of thin air it then feeds ai
algorithms with this information to
teach them how to perform certain tasks
these are all synthetically created
bags
this is like add uh add a phone and add
a lipstick like yeah you don't just
simulate the x-ray simulation right you
can simulate the packing itself you can
simulate the folding of clothes so we
have we have a lot of different
simulations on the platform so we do
satellite imagery we've done infrared
imagery we've done security cameras
we've actually done microscopy and
studied oocytes and human reproduction
so you're making like fake cells well
yeah like like fake embryos okay
sometimes you want to run tests to see
if the ai behind an expensive piece of
technology will even work
for example startups are rushing to send
satellites into orbit that photograph
the earth in different ways
they're packed full of expensive often
experimental sensors
rendered ai can help gauge if these
sensors will do the job they're supposed
to before you pay to build and launch
the satellites
you can imagine questions like hey i
want to detect forest fires right okay
i've got visible cameras in space
how much sooner can i detect a forest
fire
if i was detecting an air so you guys
could sort of like simulate what forest
fires would look like from space and do
that millions of times and then maybe we
start to see that like these patterns
emerge before one breaks out exactly
what nathan is talking about is a weird
concept the ais need information to
become good at their job and they're now
being fed by other ai systems soon he
imagines ai's training the ais to train
the ais
i mean what we're doing with synthetic
data is is about
not just training the ai but training
the tools that allow us to do this world
building and procedural generation and
it does feed on itself and absolutely
like that's going to lead to all sorts
of crazy and unexpected unexpected
things although i will say
i'd start by being able to like
successfully detect cars yeah
like it'll be really good if we can do
that really well
[Music]
everybody ready to tack yep
all right coming about
[Music]
perhaps there's a divine entity up there
with a giant computer simulating all of
this
if so
well done supreme being
but for the moment i'm gonna assume this
is real and i'm going to revel in it
next up on hello world i head to canada
to pound some maple syrup
[Music]
it's pure
and visit a not so paranoid android
[Music]
you